et pour en parler nous sommes avec
michel jallamion conseiller régional
ile-de-france front de gauche michel
jallamion bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation directe sur rt
france pour commencer peut-être une
réaction à sur les propos du président
de la république qu'il faut réagir
il alerte ce qui laisse entendre que
nous sommes en dictature comment est ce
que vous comprenez cette déclaration du
chef de l'état bah je prends ça
évidemment comme une énième provocation
de sa part c'est à dire que lorsqu'il
dit qu'en démocratie en effet on
respecte l'autre en effet en démocratie
normalement on respecte l'autre on
respecte le dialogue social avec les
organisations syndicales
on respecte que 66% des français
souhaitent le retrait de son projet de
loi est donc on fait en sorte que le
peuple trouve contentement dans la
politique que l'on mène sinon en effet
on est dans un type de régime
le qui change de l'histoire de la vème
république et aujourd'hui
ici nous assistons évidemment à des
violences policières et à des excès lors
des manifestations de la part des forces
de l'ordre c'est en effet que le régime
pour tenir doit réprimer et les gilet
jaune et les mouvements de contestation
pour se maintenir aujourd'hui ce qui
compte c'est le sentiment de l'ensemble
des français d'ailleurs qu'ils soient de
gauche ou de droite qui est que mac on
doit retirer son projet parce que ce
projet contraire à l'intérêt de
l'ensemble des français les gens l'ont
compris
il n'ya et lorsqu'on voit les dernières
déclarations également d'agnès busan qui
par un tour de passe-passe explique que
l'âge pivot est toujours dans ce texte
de loi et cetera
il faudrait que la cfdt en tire
d'ailleurs les conséquent à agnès buzyn
qui parle d'ailleurs d'un projet de
solidarité en coin pour vous ce projet
c'est pas un projet solide aéro fou ce
projet n'est pas solidaire déjà parce
qu'ils cassent la solidarité dans son
essence même alors il commence
d'ailleurs c'est assez curieux par les
hauts cadres c'est à dire jusqu'à
présent les cadres jusqu'à 27 mille euro
cotisé au régime général de la sécurité
sociale désormais ce n'est plus que
jusqu'à hauteur de 10000 euros et pour
le reste ils devront bien ils devront
cotiser pour leur propre retraite à des
dons dans des assurances privées pour
leurs assurés donc évidemment c'est un
boulevard offert aux fonds de pension
ceux qui vont payer la différence ce
sont les salariés cela va coûter 4 7
milliards aux salariés de compenser ce
fonds
et donc il n'y a rien de solidaires il
n'a rien de solidaires pour les femmes
et c'est la seule chose qui est
solidaire c'est la sécurité sociale en
elle-même
et si ce qu'ils essaient de démanteler
donc évidemment cela n'a rien de
solidaire puisque les femmes vont payer
puisque les gens les plus précaires vont
payer et ils font comme si aujourd'hui
nous a tout le monde avait une carrière
linéaire jusqu'à 62 ou 64 ans ce qui
évidemment n'est pas le cas ce qu'ils
veulent c'est enlever le pouvoir de
décision aux organisations syndicales et
mettre fin aux régimes paritaires de la
sécurité sociale pour en effet avoir un
point et que ce point soit décidée en
conseil des ministres exactement comme
le point des fonctionnaires qui est gelé
depuis des dizaines d'années est donc
abaissée l'ensemble des retraites donc
c'est vraiment une réforme pour abaisser
la retraite de tous les français du
privé comme du public
alors pour vous qui sont les grands
gagnants au fond ce sont les fonds de
pension que sont les fronts tension très
clairement puisque le but c'est de ces
de précariser un maximum les français de
leur faire peur pour leur avenir pour
qu'ils orientent une partie de leurs
économies vers les fonds de pension on a
vu avec blackrock et ses impôts intense
avec le gouvernement et par conséquent
évidemment ces fonds de pension ont tout
intérêt à capter un maximum d'argent et
pour capter un maximum d'argent il faut
précarisés la retraite des salariés pour
que les salariés le mettre de l'argent
de côté dans ses fonds de pension et ils
seront payés dès qu'il y aura une crise
ils en seront victimes et nous savons de
toute façon nous voyons à cascades et
social que l'ensemble des assurances
privées coûtent plus cher évidemment que
la solidarité nationale telle qu'elle a
été mise en place d'un conseil national
de résistance et l'intérêt du
gouvernement vous y serez ou dans cette
histoire est le font l'intérêt du
gouvernement il a assez simple c'est
faire plaisir aux fonds de pension et
aux milieux financiers d'ailleurs moi
j'avais envie aussi de m'adresser au
patronat notamment des pme pmi qui n'ont
aucun intérêt évidemment au à ce
changement de réformes il ya toutes les
réformes que fait le gouvernement qui
n'a qu'un seul intérêt c'est l'intérêt
de la finance contre l'économie réelle
et l'ensemble de l'économie réelle
justement devrait se soulever contre
c'est les agissements de ce gouvernement
alors la conférence sur le financement
souvient qu'ils avaient été réclamés par
la cfdt sera lancé le 30 janvier
prochain au ceo conseil économique
social et environnemental perspectives
intéressantes ou pas pour vous cette
cette conférence de sur le financement
mais le problème c'est comme le grand
des bandes emmanuel macron si si il
estime que le pib de la france n'a pas
la répartition du pib de la france pour
les retraites ne doit pas être modifié
alors la messe est dite les retraites
vont baisser c'est tout le problème et
ensuite on peut mettre ce que l'on veut
à l'intérieur inventer n'importe quel
système on ne fera que gérer la
précarité c'est du reste ce que fait le
gouvernement avec les services publics
avec toutes les solidarités nationales
qui existe il dit nous n'avons plus
d'argent donc trouver les moyens de
supprimer les services publics de
supprimer les solidarités
enfin j'estime et beaucoup
d'organisations syndicales associatives
et politiques estime que non qu'il ya
matière d'augmenter au contrat c'est
solidarité et notamment par
l'augmentation des cotisations
patronales et par l'augmentation des
impôts sur les plus favorisées notamment
sur les milieux financiers eux ce qu'il
veut c'est au contraire capter l'argent
des salariés pour l'orienter vers les
milieux financiers
merci beaucoup michel j'avais bien
d'avoir accepté notre invitation des
rez-de-chaussée avant je rappelle que
vous êtes conseiller régional
ile-de-france front de gauche